so we can make sure we really what
understand what's happening in this
little iterative Fibonacci function that
I wrote I'm going to step through it
with a particular example so we're going
to assume that this function is called
with the argument 5 so we want the fifth
term in the Fibonacci sequence starting
at where we're indexing things starting
at zero so the zeroth term will be the
really sometimes what you would imagine
the first term to be will start at the
zeroth term so we're assuming that
Fibonacci Fibonacci Fibonacci of 5 is
called so we want the fifth term
starting at the zeroth term so we just
want the fifth one and so when we go
into this program terms starts is
defined as this list right here that
just has two elements 0 and 1 so what
I've done here is I'm going to really
focus on what happens in this loop so as
we enter into this loop the first time
that we enter into this loop terms is
referring to a list that has just 0 and
1 in it and we did that because by
definition those are the first two those
are the first two terms of the Fibonacci
sequence and then also entering into the
loop we define I as being equal to I as
being equal to 2 and we do that because
we've already defined the 0th term and
the first term and so now we want to as
we enter the loop start we want to add
we want to add the second term as we go
into the loop and then we say while I is
less than or equal to n well we already
know that n is 5 so in the scope of this
function while we are running it the
variable n is 5 and so clearly I is
still is less than or equal to 5 so we
will run this code right over here and
we're appending two terms so we're going
to pen something so entering into this
clause this is what I in terms look like
but it looks like we're going to append
something to terms so terms is going to
look like terms is going to be 0 and 1
and then we're going to add something
we're going to add something right over
here to terms and what is that thing
we're going to add what we're going to
add whatever this business over here is
it seems complicated when you break it
down it's actually doesn't look too bad
in this situation what is I minus 1 well
I is 2 so
in this situation I minus 1 is going to
be 1 and I minus 2 is going to be 0 as
we go through this iteration so terms
the the first term in terms the first
term so this is a 0th term this is the
first term so the first term in terms is
literally a 1 so this whole thing this
whole thing is 1 and the 0th term in
terms remember terms the 0th term in
terms make sure I should write this way
0th term the the list is called terms
zeroth term in terms this is what terms
look like right looks like right now is
going to be 0 so this whole thing is
going to be 0 as well so it's 1 plus 0
which is 1 and that's what we're
appending to terms so we're going to
append a 1 over here and then we say I
is equal to I plus 1 well I is right now
equal to 2 so you're going to add 2 plus
1 is 3 and that's going to be the new
value the new value for I and then we go
back we loop back up to the beginning of
the while loop and we say while I is
less than or equal to n well now I is a
little bit closer to n it's 3 now but
it's still less than or equal to 5 so
now we evaluate this again so once again
entering into the loop terms now looks
like this 0 1 1 I looks like this 3 it's
really what the same values we had
exiting the loop and now we evaluate
right over here we're going to add
something to terms so terms right now 0
1 1 we're going to add something to it
what is that something it's going to be
the I minus 1 term of terms so what's
the I I over here is 3 3 minus 1 is 2 so
this right over here is now going to be
2 so it's going to be the the second
indexed term in terms so if the second
this is the 0th the first the second so
this is over here is going to evaluate
to 1 plus I minus 2
well I is now 3 3 minus 2 is 1 so plus
the first term in terms this is a 0 term
in the first term so this is also going
to be this is also going to be a 1 over
here this is going to be 1 plus 1 or
- one plus one or two so we're going to
append a - two terms that's what this
does over here and then we take whatever
I was which is I in this in this
iteration I is three and we're going to
add one to it and redefine I to be that
so three plus one is four and that's the
new that's the new I then we go again to
the beginning of the loop while I is
less than or equal to n well I is now
four and as always is still five four is
less than or equal to five so we run
this again and once again we need to
figure out what terms of I minus one are
let me write it over here since this is
getting all this is getting kind of
messy let me actually clear this up
because this I wanna be able to read it
clearly so let me clear this so now in
this loop let's just think about what so
now let me write it over here
entering the loop now I is equal to four
under that same orange color entering
into the loop I is equal to four and the
terms terms has now been and now has
four elements in zero one one and two
and now four is still less than equal to
five so we do this and we have to figure
out what terms of I minus one is well
now I minus one is three right 4 minus 1
is 3 so terms of or the third outlet not
terms of I should say the third element
in terms is 0
one two three so it's going to be this
whole thing is going to be this 2 right
over here so we're going to take that -
I know you can't read that we're going
to take this 2 this 2 and we're going to
add it to terms the I minus tooth terms
I is 4 4 minus 2 is 2 the second term in
terms is 0 1 2 it's a 1 it's a 1 it's
this one right over here so we're adding
this 2 Plus this 1 - now get 3 and we're
taking so this whole thing and you add
it as 3 and we are appending it to terms
so terms was 0 1 1 2 but now we are
appending a 3 to the end of it we're
appending a 3 to the end of it and then
we're saying I is equal to I plus 1 I
was 4 4 plus 1 is 5 so that is what I is
equal
now equal to five then we go over the
beginning of the loop I is now I is now
going to be equal to five terms let me
write in that same color for consistency
terms are now 0 1 1 2 & 3 and then we
say while I is less than or equal to N
and it's 5 well 5 is still less than or
equal to 5 it's equal to 5 so this still
is true so we will execute we will
execute this clause and now we have to
figure out let me clear this out again
let me clear this out again now we have
to figure out what is terms of I or what
is the I minus 1 term in terms so now I
is 5 so it's 5 minus 1 so it's the
fourth term in terms so 0 1 2 3 4 so it
is this term right over here it is the 3
it is the 3 so this over here is 3 now
and then we have and then we have to
think about we do this in another color
and then we have I minus 2 is 5 now 5
minus 2 is 3 the third term in terms 0 1
2 3 is this over here so this over here
is 2 so you evaluate this your little
notice we're just adding the last 2
terms that we had so far this is how we
build our Fibonacci sequence and so 3
plus 2 is 5 so we're going to append a 5
to the end of terms so terms is going to
be 0 1 1 2 3 and then we are going to
append we are going to append a 5 to it
and then we say I is equal to I plus 1
so I is equal to 5 plus 1 or 6 I is
equal to 6 now we go to the beginning of
the loop and it says while I is less
than or equal to n well now I is 6 and n
is has been 5 6 is not less than or
equal to 5 so this this goes this says
false so we do not we break out of the
loop and we go to I guess we stop
running it and then we go to return and
then we go to return return the nth term
in terms so remember n was 5 so what's
the fifth term
if we start at zero so this is the
zeroth term first term second term third
term fourth term fifth term and we are
done and hopefully that gives you an
understanding of why this worked and
also a little bit of the logic of how we
wrote it it's literally building up the
Fibonacci sequence the way you would
expect to it started with the first two
terms by definition it started with the
first two terms by definition and then
each time we went through the loop and
it added another term it said hey just
the new term is just going to be the sum
of the last term right now and the
second to last term and add them
together and then that will be the new
term and you keep doing that you keep
doing that until you have essentially
until you've added that nth term